نحو عام ونصف على الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا تعكس الجبهه الصوره الاكثر دقه
للصراع هناك نزاع استراتيجي على منطقه
تحتاج اليها روسيا بشده ولا يمكن
لاوكرانيا في السياسه والامن ان تتخلى
عنها منطقه البحر الاسود وشبه جزيره القرم
والمنافذ اليهما
تلقت موسكو ضربه باستهداف جسر القرم في
عمليه النوعيه هي الثانيه في اقل من عام
واحد الامر الذي تعده روسيا تهديدا
استراتيجيا وحيويا لا يمكنها التهاون
ازائه الضغط الاوكراني على القرمستمر وفي
الليله عينها تعرضت مدينه سباستوبولب
لهجمات مكثفه بنحو 30 طائره اوكرانيه
مسيره وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت ان
دفاعاتها الجويه اعترض سبعه عشره منها
واكدت ان وحداتها اسقطت احدى عشره مسيره
اخرى باستخدام وسائل الحرب الالكترونيه
ولشبه جزيره القرم اهميه جيوسياسيه عاليه
فهي ممر روسيا على المياه الدافئه الى
البحر الاسود
ومنفذها باتجاه مضيقي البوسفور والدردنيل
وصولا الى البحر المتوسط
وتعتبر مدينه سيفاستوبول مقر قياده اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي وسيطره موسكو على شبه
الجزيره تسمح للصواريخ الروسيه بتغطيه
الجزء الشرقي من اوروبا كاملا الرد الروسي
كان مزدوجا بالرسائل عسكريه انتقاميه ردا
على ضربه جسر القرم وكذلك حمل دلاله
تحذيريه
فالجيش شنه هجمات صاروخيه عاليه الدقه على
منشات اوكرانيه قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انها لتصنيع قوارب مسيره في اوديسا كما
استهدف القصف ميكولايف وكلاهما على البحر
الاسود
وتعتبران منطلقا للسفن التي تنقل الحبوب
الاوكرانيه ضمن اتفاق البحر الاسود
فالسلطات الروسيه تحذر من انها لن تستطيع
الحفاظ على امن ممرات الحبوب بعد من سحبت
من الاتفاقيه وتتهم كييف باستخدام اتفاقيه
الحبوب لاغراض عسكريه
[موسيقى]